my picture of the week shows two Syrian  boys and homes they can play outside for  the first time since war broke out  because of the ceasefire the playground  shelled wall with war signs and graffiti  that we'd Syria al-assad the toys and  one hand an old soccer ball in the other  toy gun well thinking of it playing with  toy guns might be the most normal and  universal things kids do all over the  world but for the boys in the picture  it's not just about imitating Western or  science fiction movie but they're very  brutal reality i was born in war myself  by had a chance to grow up here in peace  and when i was at the age of this boys i  actually had a toy gun to using it for  my carnival costume is cowgirl  I really hope the ceasefire will last so  for these kids the toy gun will stay a  toy  you